without taking cheap political shots can
we talk about covid19
how will
history remember the kovit 19 pandemic
what were the successes with what were
the failures
of leadership
of of man of humans
doom was a book
that i was
planning to write before yes the
pandemic struck as a history of
of the future based in large measure on
science fiction
it had occurred to me in 2019 that i had
spent too long not reading science
fiction and so i decided i would
liven up my my intake
by getting off history for a bit and
reading science fiction
because history is great at telling you
about the perennial problems of power
putin is always interesting on history
he's become something of a historian
recently with uh his essays and lectures
but what history's bad at telling you is
well what will the effects of this
discontinuity of technology be
and so i thought i need some science
fiction to think more about this because
i'm i'm i'm tending to miss
the importance of technological
discontinuity
if you read a lot of science fiction you
read a lot of of plague books because uh
science fiction writers are really quite
fond of the plague scenario
so the world ends in many ways in
science fiction but one of the most
popular is the lethal pandemic so when
when the first
email came to me i think it was on
january the third from my medical friend
justin stepping funny pneumonia and
wuhan my antennae began
to tingle because it was just like
one of those science fiction books that
begins in just that way
in a pandemic
as larry brilliant the epidemiologist
said many years ago the key
is early detection and early action
that's how you deal with a novel
pathogen
and almost no western country did that
we know it was doable because the time
and ease in the south koreans did it and
they did it very well
but really no western country got this
right
some were unlucky because super spreader
events happened earlier than in other
countries italy was hit very hard very
early
for other countries the real disaster
came quite late russia which has only
relatively recently had a really bad
experience
the lesson for me is quite different
from the one that most journalists
thought they were learning last year
most journalists last year thought
trump is a terrible president he's
saying a lot of crazy things
it's his fault that we have high excess
mortality in the united states the same
argument was being made by journalists
in britain boris johnson dot dot dot
brazil jair bolsonaro dot dot dot even
india narendra modi
the same argument
and i think this argument is wrong in a
few ways
it's true that the populist leaders said
many crazy things
and broadly speaking gave poor guidance
to their
their populations
but i don't think it's true to say
that with different leaders these
countries would have done significantly
better if joe biden had magically been
president
a year early i don't think the us would
have done much better because the things
that caused excess mortality last year
weren't presidential decisions they were
utter failure of cdc to provide testing
that definitely wasn't trump's fault
scott gottlieb's book makes that very
clear it's just been published recently
we utterly failed to use technology for
contact tracing which the koreans did
very well
we didn't really quarantine anybody
seriously there was no enforcement of
quarantine
and we exposed the elderly to the virus
as quickly as possible in elderly care
homes and
these things have very little to do with
presidential incompetence
so i think
leadership
is of somewhat marginal importance in a
crisis like this because what you really
need is your public health bureaucracy
to get it right and very few western
public health bureaucracies got it right
could the president have given
better leadership yes
his correct strategy however was
to learn from barack obama's playbook
with the opioid epidemic
the opioid epidemic killed as many
people on obama's watch as covert did on
trump's watch
and it was worse in the sense because it
only happened in the u.s and each year
it killed more people than the year
before over eight years
nobody to my knowledge has ever
seriously blamed obama for the opioid
epidemic
trump's mistake was to put himself front
and center of the response to claim that
he had some unique insight into the
pandemic and to say
with every passing week more and more
foolish things until even
a significant portion of people who'd
voted for him in 2016 realized that he'd
blown it which is why he lost the
election
the correct strategy was actually to
make mike pence
the pandemic tsar and get the hell out
the way
that's what my advice to trump would
have been in fact it was in february of
last year
so the mistake was
to to try to lead
but actually
leadership in a pandemic is almost a
contradiction in terms what you really
need is your public health bureaucracy
not to [ __ ] it up and they really really
[ __ ] it up and that was then all
blamed on trump yes you know jim fallows
writes a piece in the atlantic that says
well being the president's like flying a
light aircraft it's pilot error and i
read that piece and i thought does he
really after all the years he's spent
writing think that being president is
like flying a light aircraft i mean it's
really nothing like flying a light
aircraft being president is you sit on
top of a vast bureaucracy with how many
different agencies 60 70 we've all lost
count
and you're surrounded by advisers at
least a quarter of whom are saying this
is a disaster we have to close the
borders and the others are saying no no
we have to keep the economy going that's
what you're running on in november
so being a president in a pandemic is a
very unenviable position
because you actually can't
you can't really determine whether your
public health bureaucracy will get it
right or not you don't think to push
back on that just like being churchill
in a war is difficult
so
leaving trump abiding aside what i would
love to see from a president is somebody
who makes great speeches and arouses the
public to push the bureaucracy the
public health bureaucracy to get their
[ __ ] together to fire certain kinds of
people to do i mean i'm sorry but i'm a
big fan of powerful speeches especially
in the modern age with the internet it
can really move people instead
the lack of speeches
resulted in certain kinds of forces
amplifying division over whether wear
masks or not or all
it's like it's almost like the public
pick some random topic over which to
divide themselves and there was like a
complete indecision which is really what
it was fear
of the of uncertainty materializing
itself in some kind of division and then
you almost like busy yourself with the
red versus blue politics as opposed to
some i don't know fdr type character
just stands and say
uh
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] that we're
hearing we're going to manufacture 5
billion tests this is what america is
great at we're going to build the
greatest testing infrastructure ever
built or
something or even with the vaccine
development but that was what i was
about to interject yes
in a pandemic the most important thing
is the vaccine if you get that right
then you should be forgiven for much
else and that was the one thing the
trump administration got right because
uh they went around the bureaucracy with
operation warp speed and achieved a
really major success
so
i think the paradox of of the
the 2020
story in the united states is that the
one thing that mattered most the trump
administration got right
and it got so much else wrong that was
sort of marginal that we were left with
the impression that trump had
been to blame for the whole disaster
which wasn't really quite right
sure it would have been great if we did
operation warp speed for testing
but ultimately vaccines are more
important than tests and
this brings me to the question that that
you raised there of polarization
and why that happened
now in a book called the square in the
tower i argued that it would be very
costly for the united states to allow
the public sphere to continue to be
dominated by a handful of big tech
companies that this ultimately would
have more adverse effects than simply
contested elections and i think we saw
over the past 18 months uh just how bad
this could be because
the odd thing about this
country is that we came up with vaccines
with 90 plus percent efficacy and about
20 of people refuse to get them and
still do refuse
for reasons that seem
best explained
in terms of the anti-vaxx network which
has been embedded on the internet for a
long time predating the pandemic rene de
rester wrote about this pre-2020 and
this this anti-vax network has turned
out to kill maybe 200 000 americans who
could have been vaccinated but were
persuaded through magical thinking that
the vaccine was riskier
than the virus whereas
you don't need to be an epidemiologist
you don't need to be a medical scientist
to know that the virus is about two
orders of magnitude riskier than the
vaccine
so again
leadership
could definitely have been better
but the politicization of everything
was not trump's doing alone it
happened because our public sphere has
been dominated by a handful of
platforms whose business model
inherently promotes polarization
inherently promotes fake news and
extreme views because those are the
things that get the eyeballs on the
screens and sell the ads i mean this is
now a common place
but when one thinks about the cost
of allowing this uh
kind of thing to happen it's now a very
high human cost
and we were foolish to leave uncorrected
these structural problems in the public
sphere that were already very clearly
visible in 2016.
you